you ever heard of john rusting is this a  joke  who hasn't heard of him he was murdered  last night mr rothstein  i'm a huge fan i've been waiting for  this moment my  entire life you got the manuscripts  no what  case number 62324 ohio versus lou link  later asking 12  jurors to condemn the woman who saved  the world from mr  mercedes some kid came into the  bookstore asking about rothstein  there's somebody looking for those books  somebody who will kill  to get them we need to turn the screws  on this kit now  we're running out of time we need to get  something he wants  [Music]  you gotta get me out of here  remember i said after brady hartsfield  there'd never be another  there's another  you